1.3 million votes has decided the top 10
Sci-Fi series of all time and the list
is freaking awesome so let's discuss it
here welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV
movie channel
[Music]
now first I'll tell you that this list
has been put together by watch worthy
that is powered by Rancor there was 1.3
million votes by the general public to
generate this list so unlike a lot of
these top 10 lists it's not been decided
by somebody YouTuber like me it's not
been decided by some reporter just some
bloke who's written the story it's
actually been voted for by us and 1.3
million votes that gives us I think a
pretty good idea that this list is
really what the consensus of people
believe now there's going to be things
on this list that you don't agree with
and some of the shows on this list
aren't maybe the most you know generally
popular sci-fi shows ever made but
let's get into it and I will tell you
exactly what I think as we go along in
at number 10.
Star Trek the Original Series
it's the daddy isn't it Patrick there is
not serious is maybe not
aged particularly well for some of the
episodes but some of the episodes are
iconic some of the episodes are
generally still today some of the
greatest sci-fi we've ever seen and
actually you could argue that strange
new worlds is remainting the original
series and copying actually a lot of
those storylines
the genuinely important in our culture
and I would actually argue that some of
the episodes of the original series
changed our culture for the better
we've been trying to live up to some of
the expectations that were laid out in
the original series of Star Trek ever
since it's an ideal that Humanity should
aim for and you know we're not there yet
but
from a television point of view
four or five episodes of the original
series still stand up today and a still
excellent sci-fi so yeah it's the daddy
of the Sci-Fi it's the
show really that started the genre in
lots of ways it was proper grown-up
science fiction when a lot of the other
stuff was maybe just for kids so yeah
Star Trek in the top 10 of this list
of course in at number nine The X-Files
now I would actually argue that on this
list this is probably the most
it's the show that probably had the most
wide appeal
particularly in the early series of the
X-Files it was the most popular show on
television it made David Duchovny and
Gillian Anderson genuinely big
celebrities they were stars the will
they weren't they was genuinely a
national Obsession for a little while
I would argue that there's only one
other show on this series that actually
comes close
so from a general
popularity point of view most definitely
The X-Files deserves to be on this list
but from an actual television show point
of view is it excellent good oh God yeah
particularly the first series was
excellent we've never really seen
anything quite like it before again it
was grown up again it was mysterious but
it was kind of like sexy as well and it
was actually genuinely intriguing it was
more like a Sci-Fi soap opera in some
ways the will they weren't there again
between Fox and Mulder genuinely became
iconic there are songs written about it
so yeah number nine on this list 100 the
show Definitely Maybe outstated to
welcome it stayed on the air longer than
it should have done and I would argue as
well that a couple of the movies and
little mini series they've done since
have not been very good but
for the initial impact it had in those
first three four seasons
excellent sci-fi and generally change
the genre number eight
the Orville now
the fans of the Orville are obsessive
about it and I'm I'm one of them I think
it's absolutely brilliant so I I kind of
wish that Paramount had just let Seth
MacFarlane make a Star Trek shirt
but they didn't so he made his own and
um I think that even though there's
maybe a little bit too much Seth
MacFarlane humor in the first couple of
Seasons forced on him by executives
genuinely and honestly
the Orville Horizons New Horizons that
was out last year
was grown up proper sci-fi it still had
elements of humor but it was grown up
proper sci-fi and it was brilliant
sci-fi and if they don't come back for
another series it's genuinely a crime
against science fiction but
they're going to number seven Battlestar
Galactica now it doesn't actually say
whether that's the original or the
rebooted version of Battlestar Galactica
but let's assume Mr Ronald D Moore
version
the mini series
hand on heart the mini series of
Battlestar Galactica is some of the best
science fiction I've ever seen it had
such a massive impact on me
um the big tall blonde Cylon snapping
the baby's neck generally made me go
what the hell I honestly think if you're
talking about a lot of these series sort
of changed the genre and
people have been copying Battle Star
Galactica ever since you can actually
argue that one of my favorite shows
Stargate copied Battlestar Galactica
when they did Stargate Universe the tone
and the style of the show was very
similar
um and
a lot of other shows have copied it
since as well
um that's always the sign of a really
game-changing television show when other
people start copying you if you think
about the Matrix and the amount of
movies that copied that after it so
Battlestar Galactica number seven on
this list hell yeah again the show
towards the end maybe I've stayed at
welcome I didn't like that Caprica load
of rubbish and um to be honest I stopped
watching Battlestar Galactica first time
around towards the end I thought it
really lost its way
but the first season and in particular
the mini series were excellent Beyond
excellent to be honest number six on the
list is the only other show that I think
can challenge The X-Files for General
popularity and it's stranger things
again it's probably the most popular
show on Netflix it's become people are
obsessed about it the actors are
everywhere you know Billy Bobby Brown is
a model now and whatever else and doing
lots of movies and Etc
but but on top of that it's genuinely
brilliant television it it is Mystery we
never know what the hell is going on
with strange things you never know who's
gonna die you never know what's gonna
happen next they've been able to sort of
like change themselves as they've gone
along as well and there's been a new
great villain each year with but while
still keeping its identity it's got
brilliant characters characters you
genuinely care about and I just think
it's been a shame to be honest in a way
that it's been a victim of its own
success that we've not got to see more
of it because it was so popular the
actors then got so in demand that it's
been a diff it's been a real struggle to
then make more and the last series is
going to well we're gonna have to wait
for it but it's going to be I think
excellent and I'm really glad we're
getting a little bit more Stranger
Things number five on the list
Star Trek the Next Generation now
for me Star Trek the Next Generation is
my Star Trek it's the Star Trek I grew
upon it's the Star Trek that was on TV
when I was like 13 14. it's probably the
TV show that got me hooked on sci-fi if
it wasn't for the Next Generation I'm
not sure I would have done
it's the show that made me go out and
start looking for more sci-fi
I think it did change everything I do
actually think Deep Space Nine and
Voyager are better than Star Trek the
Next Generation in lots of ways the
production value is way better
but
the characters from Star Trek the Next
Generation will stay with us forever
data Picard Riker laforge all of these
characters will stay with us forever
they spawned one very good movie and a
couple of glass watch
um but
they genuinely again
change the genre for a little while
and
it was the first time I think we saw
really
expensive high production value sci-fi
that this wasn't a Sci-Fi show on the
Sci-Fi channel you know that's done
reasonably cheaply
um that has some very dodgy special
effects etc etc this was actually a
highly expensive Sci-Fi show made for
grown-ups
made with the intent to be
good looking television
it allowed other shows to happen after
it a little bit like the original series
that was like first of its kind but then
it allowed them to make other shows
the Next Generation did the same and we
got a lot of really brilliant sci-fi off
the back of the popularity of the Next
Generation and thank God for it number
four
my favorite show of all time what it
what might that be Stargate sg1 in a
number four I think that's amazing for
again the show there's not been on our
screens for nearly 20 years that is
incredible that this has made this list
and just one more indicator that it will
be back a Revival of Stargate sg1 is
what I'm hearing so number four on this
list absolutely bloody incredible and it
deserves to be there if you're talking
about characters you know I'm saying
about great characters and Star Trek the
Next Generation of stuff
sg1 SG wanted some of the best
characters we've ever seen in a Sci-Fi
show Jack O'Neill Sam Carter Daniel
Jackson teal indeed are really the
Pinnacle of brilliant sci-fi characters
the show went on for 10 years broke
records and it reinvented itself several
times now for me Stargate Atlantis was
just as good it didn't ever quite have
the popularity of sg1 but it was
brilliant SGU was getting better but
Stargate will 100 be back on our screens
at some point in the near future and
wholeheartedly deserves to be in number
four in this top ten number three the
Mandalorian now I suppose Star Wars had
to appear somewhere on this list
and the Mandalorian is brilliant the
Mandalorian I would actually say is the
best of the new Star Wars stuff the
movies not so good the TV okay
um I think it's very clear as well that
you know how good the character
Mandalorian is that when they did the
book of Boba Fett the only two good
episodes of the series are actually the
two that Boba Fett wasn't in that
focused on the Mandalorian so
great TV series I've seen the first
episode of the new series it's great
um I like I do find it a little slow at
times I do wish it would pick up the
pace a little bit I actually nearly
stopped watching it in the first couple
of episodes because the pace was so slow
but it's got to still be a Star Wars
series The Star Wars can be a little
slow paced so it's just it's a Star Wars
Chef
um
I love it I don't think it deserves to
be in this list or definitely not this
high up anyway if you're actually
comparing it to things like Stargate hg1
10 seasons of Brilliance even stranger
things
I think this is a little high but it may
be a little high because it's the Sci-Fi
show that's actually on our screens at
the moment
um so maybe it's you know a little bit
falsely been pushed up this list because
of that and also the new series coming
out so also I suppose Star Wars fans had
to vote for something number two on the
list
probably the most realistic grown-up
Sci-Fi show ever made one of the
cleverest sci-fi shows ever made and
again if you want to talk about
obsessive fans
the expanse fans are the really
obsessive fans they love this freaking
show now again I'm told that this will
return at some point but not on Amazon
and we hope that we will get to see more
expanse in the future potentially on
Apple TV or something like that
it never really got the widespread
popularity of other sci-fi shows on this
list a lot of people just didn't get it
Amazon didn't advertise it enough
Netflix didn't advertise it enough that
is the one downside maybe of streaming
services they don't tend to actually
like advertise their TV shows a great
deal they just sort of like hope people
will find them but anyway
the expanse deserve to have a much
bigger audience it never quite got it
but it was as I say the most realistic
most grown-up most intelligent sci-fi
we've probably ever had and if it ends
at season six it really will be a crime
let's hope we can see more of the
expanse universe so what's at number one
a Sci-Fi show that I've not mentioned so
far
we can argue about whether it deserves
to be at number one
it probably doesn't if I'm 100 honest if
it had lasted longer and we'd got
several seasons of it then maybe
but we only got 14 episodes so
put it in a number one is a bit dodgy
but
I love the show so much I can't argue
with it
and it's probably the Sci-Fi show I've
re-watched the most
Firefly
now this is a show that they keep
threatening to reboot and appearing at
top of this list
just makes that more likely but
I hope they don't because it really was
lightning and bottle it really was the
most interesting Sci-Fi show that was so
badly handled by Fox it died in its
infancy it really did but it's a show
that I adore
as I said I have rewatched this so many
goddamn times you wouldn't you know I
was watching it yesterday literally
yesterday I watched the train job
yesterday
um the characters
were just extraordinary they loved each
other offset and it shows and they
apparently still have a Serenity Valley
um WhatsApp group and they still talk to
each other all the time
if the only way they could bring the
show back is if they got Nathan feeling
to come back they need to cancel the
rookie and bring Nathan Fillion back in
there and I'd watch it other than that
don't reboot it
um
but it was
a crime that this show got handled
mishandled the way it did but I also say
that it was advertised wrong even I
didn't want to watch it when it came out
I thought space Western I looked stupid
I'm not watching that I only watched it
when the DVD boxer came out and it was
20 quid and I thought I'll give it a go
um and then fell in love with it
immediately
I was so glad we had very least got a
movie out of it a movie that some people
have criticized and I actually still I
adore I thought it was great they should
never have killed wash yeah but other
than that Lee following other than that
it's a great movie
um I would love to see it return with
Nathan Fillion and the rest of the stars
coming back in a Revival at some point
let's hope so
I'm not sure about it being at number
one of this list I will
be honest but at the same time I can't
argue with it because it's a show I love
with all my heart so that's the top 10
list as voted by 1.3 million people
what would have been your top ten do you
agree with me on some of the maybe
criticisms that I've got on the list or
is there something that these 1.3
million people have forgotten about get
in the comments and tell me what you
think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you can join us on patreon where you get
to see most of our videos first for a
small fee no adverts
as always please stay safe I'll see you
next time
[Music]